This is the first question. I just had a cholesterol test taken a blood test and my numbers moved up. A total cholesterol has always been high 214 to 280 and jumped from 214 to 231 HDL stayed steady LDL jumped up, triglycerides always find currently 88 and currently, but a low dose of statin to do not want to increase it.
I have some ideas for me. Well, I can't tell anybody to take or not to take a statin, but honestly, I'm totally not a fan of statins.
I'm totally not a fan of what is considered normal and therefore high cholesterol either.
When I was in school, high cholesterol was considered over 250, then they dropped it down to 220, then they dropped it to 200, now they dropped it to 180. Why? So that they could sell more statins.
Boy, that's cynical, but honestly, it's true. So what is a normal cholesterol? Well, the truth is all your normal blood levels are normal for the general population that necessarily normal for you, but you're truly concerned with cancer is low cholesterol.
So it's common with cancer and with progression of cancer is when you're cholesterol plumbers to like 120. That's a dangerous sign. Having high cholesterol is not good, but you want to look at why you have high cholesterol. Certainly don't have high cholesterol because you have a deficiency in statins.
Almost always a person has increased in cholesterol, but it is clinically relevantly increased. It's because of some congestion in the liver. Therefore, your body makes more cholesterol. That's where people struggle with a clean up my diet of eating perfectly in my cholesterol didn't really budge.
It's because really only about 3% of your cholesterol blood cholesterol has any relationship to your diet, except that a bad diet can cause congestion in the liver. So if you eat a lot of chemicals, process foods, etc.
Problem is is that once we end up with fatty liver disease, even when we clean up our diet and do a lot of really good things like detoxification, doesn't necessarily clean up the fatty liver disease. That still exists. So that is a major issue with cholesterol.
Personally, I don't worry about cholesterol until it's over 320. And then you start doing some things, but there's certainly multiple nutritional things that you can do for high cholesterol.
Off the top of my head, burberry, it can be good for high cholesterol.
Let's see.
Oh, I'm proud of that we had from orthobacteria.
That was good for cholesterol.
Oh, I have to think of it now.
Remember, as we go through this.
Let's talk to you.
So,
Secondly, my hemoglobin A1c was at 5.6, and he higher had to be considered pre-diabetic.
Is there, this was alarming to me as I've never been overweight, no, or had a thought of diabetes.
I was in a little homework and found that high levels of vitamin C and E and ZIG plus high cholesterol can elevate people go to A1c, wondering if I should adjust by supplements.
No, I wouldn't.
You're taking vitamin C E and ZIG to stimulate in a muted response.
So,
you don't want to decrease that to get your hemoglobin A1c down.
I would want to look at other things that we have going on with your diet first before I would, before I would do that.
Yes, I don't know who asked this question.
So, maybe set up a time to talk about that specifically.